Uh, brother, I just want to uh I mean I
I I see sometimes uh comments whether
now or uh even when I was in the studios
with David, somebody came in and rebuked
us for being harsh, you know, and I'm
like, well, gee,
>> you know, so what uh uh that we're being
harsh uh for defending the the Bible and
the gospel and sharing the truth. So, I
just wanna for the sake just of everyone
uh because I sense some people sometimes
get irritated when they hear you calling
people son of the devil you know and
things like that.
>> You got some passages. Oh, you want me?
Well, let me read them. Can I read them
for you?
>> I mean, I'm going to just read just what
Jesus himself was saying to the
Pharisees in Matthew 23 and you can add
to that.
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, I just need people's opinion on
that. You know, what do they think if
Jesus was loving or not? calling the
Pharisees and the scribes basically
hypocrites, right? That mean he called
them hypocrites. Then he called them for
instance in Matthew 23:15
a very interesting thing. He says, "Woe
to you scribes and Pharisees hypocrites
for you travel across sea and land to
make a single procelite. And when he
becomes a proelite, you make him twice
as much a child of hell as yourselves.
So he's calling him the children of
hell. Well, gee, man. I don't think
>> calls him brute of wipers.
>> Exactly. Wine guides, you know. So, I
don't know what people uh are talking
about sometimes when they get irritated
and upset. Obviously, they don't know
anything about what Jesus was doing.
>> Yeah. Let me let me give you a few more.
I already had to write an article on
this. Okay. Now, I'm going to give a few
more. It's because they've confused
westernized sisified Christianity with
true biblical Christianity and spiritual
piety. This is another group that
disgusts me. They think that they've
correctly understood what it means to be
Christlike, humble, and pious when in
reality it's their cultural influence
because they're westerners who follow
westernized version of Christianity.
It's a feminite and cisified. They think
that is Christianity. Now, let me read
how Paul and others treated unbelievers.
Okay, let me read. Now, you're going to
say, "Well, you're no Paul." Okay, well,
damn if I do, damn if I don't. Here,
you're telling me, "Be like Jesus and
Paul." When I showed you Jesus and Paul
are harsh to blasphemers and sons of the
devil who pervert the truth, they'll
say, "Well, you're not Jesus or you're
not Paul." So, make up your mind. Do you
want me to imitate Jesus and Paul or do
you want me not to imitate them? Or do
you just want me to imitate them when
you when it suits your purpose or agrees
with your understanding of what it's
like to be pious? Well, here let me read
Acts 13 6-12. Among many Acts 13 6-12
when they had gone through the whole
island as far as Pathos, they came upon
a certain magician. Acts 13 6-12. Note
it down guys. Paul is filled with the
Holy Spirit when he says this. Came a
certain magician, a Jewish false prophet
named Bar Jesus. He was the pro he was
with the proconsul Sergius Paulus a man
of intelligence who summoned Barnabas
and Saul and sought to hear the word of
God. But Elmas the magician for that is
the meaning of his name opposed them
seeking to turn the proconsel away from
the faith. But Saul was also called Paul
filled with the Holy Spirit looked
intently at him and said you son of the
devil Paul shame on you dude.
Shame on you. Don't you know you're not
being humble, Christlike? I don't see
Jesus in you. Love your enemy, Paul.
Love your enemy, Paul. You son of the
devil, you enemy of all righteousness,
full of all deceit and villain. Will you
not stop making crooked the straight
path of the Lord? And now, behold, the
hand of the Lord is upon you, and you
will be blind and unable to see the sun
for a time. Immediately mist and
darkness fell upon him and went about
seeking people to lead him by the hand.
Then the probe counsel believed when he
saw what had occurred for he was
astonished at the teaching of the Lord.
Now a few more. Let me give you a few
more. What does Peter call false
teachers, Bible perverts who pervert the
scripture, mislead people into following
damnable doctrines? He's inspired by the
spirit. Second Peter 2:12. 2 Peter 2:12
and 19-22. 2 Peter 2:12 19-22.
But these men blasphe in manners they do
not understand. They are like brute
beasts, creatures of instinct, born only
to be caught and destroyed. And like
beasts, they too will perish. So now you
effeminate if I call you an
animal, a beast, a wild animal, a beast
good for nothing but destruction. Are
you going to say I'm not being
Christlike? Oh, but wait, let me
continue the rest of it. verses 19 and
22. Okay, watch here.
They promised them freedom while they
themselves are slaves of depravity. For
a man is a slave to whatever has
mastered him. If they have escaped the
corruption of the world by knowing our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ, and are
again entangled in it and overcome, they
are worse off at the end than they were
at the beginning. It would have been
better for them not to have known the
way of righteousness than to have known
it and then to turn their backs on the
sacred command that was passed on to
them. Now watch this. Of them the
proverbs are true. A dog returned to its
vomit and a so meaning a pig, a swine
that is washed goes back to her
wallowing in the mud. So Peter called
these Bible perverts, these fake
Christians who pervert scripture,
blasphe the Lord and mislead people,
animals, beasts, dogs and pigs.
So whoever complain, let me say, you are
a pig, you're an animal, you're a beast,
you're a dirty dog, and you're good for
nothing to be destroyed and sent to
hell. Now condemn me and say I'm not
being Christlike. Go ahead, sit on your
horse. Finally. Well, two more. Let me
show you what Jeremiah by orders of God
called God's people. Jeremiah,
God told Jeremiah, "Say this to my
people." Jeremiah 4:22, "For my people
are foolish. They know me not. They are
stupid children. So now, what if I call
you a fool, an idiot, stupid
Would you then condemn me? They have no
understanding. They are wise and doing
evil. But how do you do good? They know
not." Now Jeremiah 10:8 and 14. Jeremiah
10 verse 8 and 14. They are both stupid
and foolish. The instruction of idols is
but wood. Every man is stupid and
without knowledge. Every goldsmith is
put to shame by his idols. For his
images are false and there is no breath
in them. So if I call you an idiot, a
a fool. You stupid idiot. Because
you have no knowledge that means you're
an idiot. You stupid You filthy
dog. You're going to say, "Sam, I don't
see Jesus in you." Well, I guess Jesus
wasn't in Jeremiah. Jesus wasn't in
Paul. Jesus wasn't in Peter. But Jesus
is only in you. You see why you disgust
me? You effeminate sissies. You disgust
me. But now, let me leave you with this.
Let me leave you with this very harsh
language of scripture.
Very harsh. God inspiring Malachi.
God inspiring Malachi chapter 2:es 1-3.
God is disgusted. Malachi chapter 2:es
1-3. God is disgusted with his priests
who are offering defective animals.
Animals who are defective.
Okay, look what he says to them. Malachi
2:es 1-3. Okay. And now, O priest, this
commandment is for you. This is inspired
scripture. Don't tell me you're holier
than God, purer than God, and you speak
better than God does, then you are truly
a dog of the of the devil. And now, O
priest, this commandment is for you. If
you will not listen, and if you will not
take take it to heart to give honor to
my name, says the Lord of hosts, I will
send a curse on you and I will curse
your blessings. Yes, I have cursed them
already because you do not take it to
heart. Now, notice verse three. You
sissies who think you are spiritual and
pious, I rebuke your descendants. Now
watch what God says he's going to do
with their defective animals. And I will
spread refuge. This is a G-rated. Go
look at the Hebrew word. I will spread
on your faces and the of your
solemn feast I will be I will be taking
away from it. Will be taken away from
it. I'm going to take the that's
literally the Hebrew. the crap of the
animals and I'm going to smear it on
your faces. This is what God says. So
now I want to I want you effeminate
sissies to tell me this is unbecoming
language, uncristlike language. So you
sit on judgment of God and say that God
is not as pure as you sissies. You guys
are fake. You're not Christian. You
disgust me because you think your fake
piety is biblical. If God will inspire a
prophet to say, "Tell them I want to
take the of them animals and I want
to smear on their faces." If I said
that to you, you'd condemn me to hell.
You fake sissies who think you're
Christian.
Okay, there you go.
>> All right, that was a u a very intense
session.
>> Not a bad crowd. We have about 270 at
our peak. We had about 270. Yeah.